two suspected drive-by shootings this
week have people across our community
concerned tonight we do thank you for
joining us I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftus the first happening outside
of Middle School in the Northeast Valley
Monday the second left two kids hurt in
a quiet neighborhood in the Northwest
sources saying both are Gang Related
Sasha Loftus spoke with Community
Advocates tonight who shared their plans
to try and keep our children safe she
joins us live with more
Denise and Brian this is where the area
where that most recent shooting happened
here in the Northwest Valley it's
normally one of the quietest part of
parts of town so that's why people who
live here say they're understandably
concerned The Advocates I spoke with
tonight say it's a sign action needs to
be taken
it's crazy scary
I didn't know what happened two shooting
people across our community shaken this
is just violence that just shouldn't
happen a campus monitor hit by a stray
bullet Monday outside Von tobel Middle
School in the Northeast Valley then a
day later two kids were shot in this
neighborhood near Durango and Elkhorn
and then I come outside and they're like
slumped over 18 year old Jesse Rios was
arrested in connection with the first
and sources tell R8 news now
investigators both situations are
gang-related it is a community problem
and the community has to be the solution
Pastor Troy Martinez is the founder of
dads and schools a volunteer
organization that promotes safety for
kids he says this is an issue that needs
to be addressed Metro Police statistics
show 21 percent of murders so far this
year involved a gang member so his plan
is more presence and interference early
on it is our job from the community to
stop gangs from recruiting in our
elementary middle and high schools this
as those affected say they're still
trying to wrap their head around what
happened I was scared as they have a
whole new take on safety here at home
it's kind of got me a little shaking up
a little bit
now there was also a car in the
neighborhood here in the Northwest
Valley that had multiple bullet holes
from that shooting neighbors tell us
that the two kids that were shot were
near that car when this happened police
are still searching for a suspect in
this second situation reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now